here is how to set up a chessboard by
knowing just three things
first White on the right make sure a
light square is in the bottom right hand
corner you get this right and you have
already succeeded where countless movie
Producers have failed
you probably know that all the pieces go
on the first and last rows but it's
important to get their placements
correct
the White Queen goes on the center most
light square and the black queen goes
directly across from her on the center
most dark Square the Kings then go at
their site
third the remaining pieces go in height
order from Center out that means Bishops
next to royalty then Knights and then
Rooks in the corner
time to wrap up with the hardest part
yet you put the Pawns in front of the
pieces okay that was actually the
easiest part remember these three things
and you've got it white on the right
Queens on their color tallest to
smallest let's play